♪♪
Allie:
They found us.
We need to go.
♪♪
On the one hand Mosquito Coast
is a straight up pure adventure
story
Justin:
about a family that is on the
run.
Justin:
And needs to get to a
destination
to gain safety for themselves
and their family.
But the other story is a very
determined man who manipulated
his family to do things that
they wouldn't normally want to do or need
to do.
-Leaving where?
-America.
Why?
This family has secrets and has
problems, financial and emotional
and otherwise.
Neil:
But, instead of leaning
further into that family drama,
we explode it.
(Police sirens)
Whatever they did in their
past they're individuals
who raged against the machine
and now they're
people who are on the run from
the law.
I think they're doing everything
to find a new civilization
Melissa:
that's gonna save them and
give them the normal life
Melissa:
that they have been dreaming
of.
♪♪
We need to tell the kids.
Margot:
They could get hurt.
It'll be an education.
♪♪
Allie Fox, he's an incredibly
bright man.
Justin:
He's pursuing his own desires
and not necessarily his
family's.
Justin:
Sort of a fine line between doing
whats right for your family
Justin:
and then being emotionally
manipulative
Justin:
to get what you want.
Allie, we're really in
trouble.
And we just make the move and
we start again.
♪♪
Melissa:
You look at these people that
think they're the perfect parents
and they're doing the right thing
to give their children a better
life.
♪♪
They're totally isolated from the
rest of the world.
Gabriel:
No internet, no technology at
all.
And just like living as they own
tribe island basically.
Han Solo, from the movie?
We don't really watch movies or
TV shows.
♪♪
Mostly just read books and
stuff.
Dina has been home-schooled.
Her only friends are her parents
and her brother.
Login:
She's really looking for
just, structure.
Login:
Because that's anything that
she has yet to have.
♪♪
I think by exposing this family
to the kind of the, the furnace
of experience,
Neil:
We begin revealing to the viewer
and to each other
their true nature.
You're better off with your
Mother and I.
♪♪
In what world? Do you know how
deranged you sound?
♪♪
Rupert:
How you deal with that
situation.
Rupert:
How you respond to it both
externally and internally,
I think makes for really good
story telling.
♪♪
There's just something
compelling about
this very thrilling ride that
they're on.
(Allie laughing)
♪♪
Trust me, we'll be fine.